so all across Canada right now we're
seeing a bunch of lgbtq protests in
regards to Pride months being involved
in schools the government has come down
saying it may be illegal not to
celebrate pride month
um basically say it goes against the
human rights Charter of said Province to
not celebrate pride month at school so
parents don't want their kids to be
indoctrinated lgbtq folks for hey we're
not doing that it helps with awareness
and acceptance here's a teacher telling
Muslim Students that skipping lgbtq
events is not okay
because you think if there's some pride
activities going on at school right oh
that's fine you know because I'm going
to show my opinion by hanging out at the
mall
but meanwhile
all those kids who are you know involved
in say the Patriot lives or whatever I
don't even know if we have that anymore
in our school they're here when we did
Ramadan for lion time and they're
showing respect in the class for your
religion right for your beliefs
it goes two ways if you want to be
respected for who you are if you don't
want to suffer Prejudice for your
religion your color of skin your
whatever then you've got to give it back
to people who are different from you
that's how it works it's an exchange
and it isn't like that in all countries
as I told you in Uganda literally if you
they think your date they will execute
you if you believe that kind of thing
then you don't belong here
because that is not what Canada believes
we believe in
Freedom so if you don't participate in
Pride events you do not belong in Canada
interesting
listen I don't know what Ramadan is like
today but when I was growing up you did
it if you wanted to you did it and
nobody cared and honestly I didn't care
if the school got involved why would I
give a [__] I'm fasting I don't need you
guys to eat sambuses with me we're not
going to be there when I break my fast
all right you guys call it samosas
whatever the [__] you call it okay yo
sambuca's inspired that's what we call
it I want to be there when y'all
[__] eat it that [__] is
delicious but my whole point is like
Muslims have never been clamoring for
other people to observe their religious
experiences they don't care just don't
[__] with our [__] and I think most
people agree you want to do this lgbtq
stuff nobody cares they just say just
don't [__] with our [__] we won't [__]
with yours
but this whole thing about like you
don't belong here if you're not willing
to participate in Pride events is
nonsensical
okay if you want as an adult to
encourage people to go to Providence
there's nothing wrong with that but
saying people don't belong here because
they don't want to go to your pride
parade is stupid and this is a bit like
I'm for people having discussions about
lgbtq rights in schools during practice
I don't think that's a problem okay I
don't care that people want to say like
you know the history of gay people in
Canada there's nothing wrong with that
but when you want to run like drag queen
shows or running stuff like drag hour
for kids or whatever like it's okay with
parents saying like I don't want that
for my kids the same way I don't think
there's anything wrong with not being
accepting of like a Muslim Shake coming
to your school to talk to the kids or a
pastor coming to you it's okay
you don't have to be for all of that
stuff but we've now made it where if
you're not 100 with us you're 100
against it but why does it have to
involve me why why does my participation
have to be part of this process that is
a question I think a lot of people are
asking and I think there's actually a
lot of school programs that are running
Pride months and their events very
sensibly okay I really believe that in
that they're not you know over indulging
they're just saying hey we got this flag
up here and beyond that like we're
chilling okay and maybe we talk about
gay people and what they've experienced
which I don't think is bad
but then you have other stuff that I'm
just like what the [__] am I even
looking at like this
[Applause]
[Music]
what am I watching now does anybody in
this room know how to twerk
and then you just move your thumb up and
down like that and that's twerking
what do you think about lgbtq stuff
being involved in Pride in schools you
think it's good bad in between the level
of what it's done okay sometimes yeah
people are trying to do too much
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
like it was like Black History Month
let's just put the examples that I can
streamline because that's what you
[__] are gonna go to first if
you talk about history the history of of
of black people I understand that but if
I would walk in one day and my kids are
in school and I picked them up and
everybody's has a black lives matter
shirt and they're not an African flag an
African flag yeah I actually want to see
that hold on I don't want to see that
one other people are talking to me like
why kids come to me like good morning
sir
I apologize for what we've done Mister
that would be too much and I'd be like I
don't want none of this [__]
cause that's too much I kind of want to
see hotep reading dick Jesus he was not
black
and so was your ancestors know your
history because we are all one people
coming from Africa take it back to the
motherland because we are standing on an
Empire of sand the West is a lie girl I
don't want you to die my white people
used to be black people used to be one
people poems rhyme like what poems
because we have cultivated a country of
hosts I do not want you to be hold out
by your government to the people of
another government as we engage in War
soldiers or [__]
that's pretty fire potent no tip there
was some good we got Umar Johnson
in the building giving you the Johnson
of knowledge
it's like if I if my daughter comes back
home all right there's a kid she's
chilling with a kid a little white kid
white and a white kid is white oh yeah
that's great that's great and he starts
clapping like that I'll be like your kid
your friend is a widow there's why why
is this why what's going on what's this
claps are oppressive snaps
or kindness there are ways to undo white
supremacy through low Sound Vibrations
crystals
African mythology
you just aren't in touch with the
motherland brother and so right now you
were using the oppressors language it's
okay it's not your fault you've been
indoctrinated much like AI is
indoctrinated the youth you are having
an opportunity to be indoctrinated by
white supremacy through the
indoctrination that we have on
television through your TV set your
movie set your phone set through your
television your computer your tablets
every day you are being programmed my
brother chat GPT is the new CIA
are you done Dr Abba Zaba Zulu King the
third never forget politics
over
punani Consciousness over coochie
politics over a punani Consciousness
over coochie the black cars will not be
televised keep it in your head the black
cause will not what be televised
black queens forever Snow Buddies never
okay back to pride month wait no
heterosexual couples only like I was
saying pride month is the way that they
will eliminate the black man by making
our children gay what they are doing is
ensuring the fact that none of us
reproduce through this
lgbtqia plus indoctrination carry on all
right
all this to say
when they're doing too much like Abba
just did
[Music]
it's weird
it's just [__] weird
shut the [__] up [__]
number for a bro no when you do when
they do too much it's just that's too
much it's weird no matter what it is I
think on both sides people need to
not go to extremes and stuff like that
but that will never happen you know
people are the way they are and it's an
Utopia to be to be like to think that
people are not gonna go on the streams
but Jesus [__] Christ on one I
understand both parties
both sides I understand both sides when
they say yeah there's nothing there's
nothing inherently bad
into drag hours and stuff like that
where it's a Jack Person drag queen a
jack person doing stories and stuff like
that I don't have a problem with that
it's the extremes and the debate amount
where it could go to have a problem with
at the same time on the other side
the people that are against that
are going to go to some Extreme as well
you know I mean it's it's both there's
extreme in both in both sides you know I
mean I could I could understand and show
where there's drag queens the nudity
doesn't belong in a school
like in the same way whenever you see
twerking to kids and this and that or
whatever whatnot which exists and which
happened that thing that you just told
us happened I want to see my girl my
little girl going to school and be like
coming back from school and be like yes
I was a day honey oh yeah I was just out
there it was a cool day out I had a pole
dance class today even if it's a pole
dance class and it's done for Fitness
you cannot remove the sex work part
after that sorry you can't you're not
disturbing it is but I imagine kids
being pole dancing is just weird to me
it is weird but I'll disagree with you
on this point I say with the parents
because I think it's a parent's job to
be overprotective of their children
that's what parents do yeah which is
right like you can't expect a parent to
be like just trust them what are you
what are you against yeah like you say
you understand both sides what I'm
saying the one that makes the most sense
is the parent side because my parents
are thinking about their kids safety and
their wealth we agree it's not like
they're imagining aliens coming down
from the sky they're imagining stuff
that they've actually seen other schools
do and here's the big problem the reason
reason why the other side of the drag
side loses a lot of its steam is because
when crazy [__] happens instead of condo
instead of like saying it's not okay
they condone it they're like well no you
guys don't understand it's not like yo
you make all of yourselves look crazy
when you're constantly supporting the
fact that like you got kids doing drag
stuff or you got kids doing this and you
might think that's okay but I side with
most parents who pulled on this matter
say they don't think it's acceptable I
don't think that's not just right
leaning parents that's also left-leaning
parents who don't think some of this
stuff is acceptable I don't think it's a
problem that parents take out their kids
from music activities I don't say that's
a problem no I don't see where the
problem is there that happened too in
Ontario which is fine well during the
pride thing I think it was like
40 or 60 of the kids didn't go to school
those days which is fine and I don't
think that that that's a problem where I
have a problem is they both demand and
then you have kids stepping on flags and
stuff like that oh that's kind of weird
but no I don't have a problem with kids
not going to certain schools certain
events that's fine
as a matter of fact when I was a kid my
school was Catholic
I was Protestant
so whenever they had
Bible study is cool
I was not going
my parents said when that class is
happening
you're not going
it was not a disrespect to the Catholic
the Catholics it was not a disrespect it
was cool me uh that was Protestant
another friend that I had that that was
uh
uh Jehovah's Witness a couple of
questions right
whenever Bible study comes around you
get to stay home yeah because no matter
where you're from Bible study is but no
no not because you got a day off to get
chilling no no I was not home I was not
home I was in another class I was not
having Bible
if I know this Pride stuff's happening
you know the first thing I'm doing is
I'm snitching to my Muslim parents you
wanna know why because we get to stay
home [__] and I love staying me hey I
wasn't
to play
through class I was another class and
you get to read that book and while
reading that book bruh it was a break
for me from the rest of that that is
cool and because I needed it I was
snoozing you understand what I'm saying
let me take a nappy nap and not bother
you just
just if I snore bruh I'll be in the
quarter but uh all that to say I'll be
telling my parents bro bro I think they
bring in a gay Pastor to the school they
want to convert me to Islam No they want
to convert me to Christianity and to
homosexuality bro let me stay home I
don't want to be gay Mom I don't want to
be Christian I might be like you stay
home for the whole week thank you Mom
I'm gonna be a good Muslim friend I'll
be playing video games I'll be making
[__] up of course yeah I'll be bringing
Flyers I'll be playing both sides I've
been going to school I'll be like yo I
think we need to organize more lgbtq
events I thought be going home like Mom
can you believe what they they trying to
turn me gay [__] yeah they want me to
suck bro one of the teachers said Lick
this Popsicle I ain't going back
Abby
Avi have you guys ever had a snow day if
you don't know what snow day is it's
when it snows so hard everybody got to
stay home parents get mad because
they're like [__] we don't have a
babysitter the school is supposed to do
that but the kids be happy as [__]
because you get to stay home and chill
out on a Wednesday don't leave my life
you remember the snow days yeah we
didn't have much
we didn't have much not as much as they
have now every day is a [__] snow day
anyways all that's insane my bad it was
not a disrespect to nobody
pulling me out of those classes was not
a disrespect to nobody that was not just
their fate so carry on you see what
happens now I hate all churches
but messages like this were quickly
drowned out by the noise of a rowdy
crowd
students tearing through Pride posters
and dancing on Pride Flags you said you
had a problem with kids stomping on the
flag
yeah why because that's that's a that's
where we go into disrespectful you know
I mean where you don't go into a certain
activity it's just like I'm not going to
partake for this and that you're not
honestly disrespecting partner person
you're not necessarily disrespected a
person but stomping on a flag just
what's pumping on a flag means right
just knowing that a flag is not even
supposed to to touch the ground you
putting it on the ground around the flag
is not supposed to go on the ground now
you put it on the ground and you stump
it let me ask you go ahead why if a kid
wants to stomp on a flag why can't they
I don't want them to stomp on the Fly
because that it shows violence it shows
it's what what it means to stomp on a
flag right it's the violence with
stomping on the flag what that means it
means that you're disrespecting the
whole thing yeah you're disrespecting
you're dirtying the flag you're
disrespecting it you're it's not it's
okay to say that you don't involve or
you don't believe in that or you don't
want none of that to happen with you but
stomping on a flag that's that's that's
a line that I wouldn't cross it's highly
disrespectful
highly disrespectful I think when you
make that kind of stuff mandatory and
you force it on people their reaction is
to stop on it I don't think they would
ever stomp on it if they weren't making
this stuff mandatory and forcing it on
people they're not stomping on the flag
to say [__] LGBT people they're saying
we don't want this forced on us it's a
different thing I can understand that I
understand what you're saying and why
it's happening I'm still not for it
happening yeah well listen
you can just they push they push kids
and they push kids to wear lgbtq flags
they make them wear it on their heads
they make them put on the colors they
make them do all kinds of weird stuff
and these are 19 20 propaganda keep on
going what what they doing
okay
they're pushing the kids to do that
right and look I think it's kind of
weird because I don't even think kids
really have the mental capacity to
really understand all the political
implications of like donning these flags
and stuff like that but they push the
kids to do it so for me if other kids
are stopping on it I really don't care
we're already pushing kids to like adopt
these political symbols whether they
really understand it or not and then
after they do that then they're saying
well you can't do it this way for me you
want to stop on it you want to wear it
if if one's okay all of them are okay I
don't think it's a good thing what I'm
trying to say is we're already pushing
our kids into that political Arena and
as far as them stomping on it I really
believe that this is only because it's
being mandatory and not because they
actually have a deep issue with lgbtq
people because I don't think I've seen
this kind of stuff generally outside of
protests in regards to like mandatory
rights sure so that's why I stand on
it's a stomping on the flag anyways I
think all in all the cultural War stuff
has really reached new heights I think
there's a lot of fear surrounding it
some of it a bit irrational but I also
also understand because the side was
whom this fear is geared towards hasn't
done a good side from dissing itself
from extremism and then they get they
get lumped in with it right so when you
see you know Biden talking about well we
get puberty blockers to minors and we
should make all this stuff accessible to
kids it's like yeah a lot of parents who
are against this kind of [__] are going
to be live I don't know if I [__] with
that and you have the highest forms of
government endorsing this stuff and why
am I talking about American politics on
a Canadian issue it's because you
realize when it comes to a media level
Canadian parents are seeing videos from
America they're seeing videos from the
UK they're seeing videos from Canada
none of this stuff is borders anymore
none of this even though the laws might
be different in different places the
fear and the cultural involvement feels
the same in all of these different
places oddly enough so yeah cultural War
stuff is real you're seeing protests and
fights breaking out in America in Canada
even in the UK and I don't think this
stuff is going to go down I think we're
just seeing a bit of it now and it's
only going to go higher from here but
there's the next election cycle I'm
expecting a lot more
anything else no all right let us know
what you guys think in the comments